hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine torte und für eine
ganz besondere torte ich habe nämlich
eine eistorte gebacken
die tat ist eigentlich was für mich und
für den rat denn ich habe hier einen
leckeren biscuit habe eine war ein haare
ein vanille kaffee drin ein zimtparfait
und das ganze ist noch mit schokolade
überzogen oder halb dekoriert und
getränkt habe ich die torte noch mit
espresso ganz viele geschmäcker die wir
beide sehr mögen in einer trance frisur
und er vereinbart verbunden verbunden
espresso und sind schon zwei sachen wo
ich über alles liebe schokolade
man sieht sie bei mir auch ein bisschen
auf jeden fall ja eine eistorte das
heißt man kann die torte machen im
tiefkühlfach aufbewahrt und einfach nach
bedarf nach lust und laune sich immer
mal wieder ein stückchen rausschneiden
vor allem finde ich jetzt gerade an den
warmen tagen immer eine super
alternative zu normalen torten
es ist so ein bisschen erfrischend und
ich habe eben hier auf das eis selber
gemacht und das finde ich eben richtig
klasse es ist nicht schwer ist nicht so
schwer die torte herzustellen und
essingen fragen wir direkt an ich werde
zuerst den bizkit backen und später dann
die kaffee masse machen für den biskuit
teig brauche ich feiere vier esslöffel
heißes wasser 120 gramm zucker jeweils
75 gramm mehl und stärke zwei teelöffel
backpulver 1 esslöffel kakaopulver eine
prise salz und in eine prise zimt und
etwas von den extrakt staatlich direkt
mit dem business da kommen jetzt die
feier in einer rührschüssel da kommt sie
viel wasser mit dazu
da lassen sich die eier einfach besser
aufschlag dann noch der zucker extrakt
gerade so ein bisschen und es lasse ich
jetzt in etwa vier bis fünf minuten weiß
cremig rühren
so sollte jetzt die eierstöcke mischung
aus sie hinten hat so richtig voluminös
und jetzt geben die trockenen zutaten
mit rein das war gebe ich die alle durch
einen see zu gehen die klümpchen raus
und ich habe eine schöne glatte bis
mitmacht und das ganze hab ich jetzt mit
einem schneebesen vorsichtig unter
und jetzt will ich den biskuit teig in
eine vorbereitete backform da habe ich
einen tortenring auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und der liegt jetzt hier auf
einer backe und auf einem backblech
natürlich jetzt den teig rein
und so wird der teig jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad für
ungefähr 25 minuten gebacken und danach
muss ich ihn abheben lassen
der biss gezeigt ist abgekühlt und den
lasse ich jetzt hier einfach mal noch
kurz stehen und werde jetzt die
eisgrenze bereiten und zwar mache ich
jetzt ein paar veh das ist das besteht
aus einer masse die wir dann mit sahne
vermengt und ich mache jetzt einmal eine
wann ein vanille kaffee und ein mal eins
im café dafür zeige ich euch mal die
zutaten für das parfait brauche ich
sechs gramm magazine oder zwei blätter
gelatine zwei eier und 2 eigelbe und 80
gramm zucker das sind die grundzutaten
und die brauche ich zwei mal hier habe
ich sie auch nochmal gerichtet und dann
brauche ich noch zwei teelöffel sind und
etwas vanille extrakt und zum trinken
der böden noch etwas espresso nach
belieben und jeweils 250 milliliter
sahne also insgesamt 500 so jetzt wenn
ich zuerst einmal darf vanille kaffee
herstellen und es warm ist jetzt die
eier zuckermasse erhitzen und es geht
jetzt einmal entweder in einer
küchenmaschine wo ihr das dann machen
könnt oder ihr macht es im wasserbad
also in der küchenmaschine sieht es
jetzt so aus er gibt zucker und eier und
eigelb in die küchenmaschine da kommt
jetzt vanille extrakt mit dazu und da
könnte jetzt wirklich einen ganzen
teelöffel mit ryan geben damit auch
richtig toll nach vanille schmeckt wobei
das ja vanilla konzentrat ist und jetzt
stelle ich die küchenmaschine auf 80
grad und lasst sie dann etwa fünf
minuten auf früheren also schaumig
rühren auf höchster stufe
und weil sie das jetzt auch über dem
wasserbad macht müsste jetzt wasser zum
kochen bringen und eine metallschüssel
nehmen da die eier zucker mischung
eingeben und mit dem handrührgerät
einfach fünf minuten lang rühren
etwa fünf minuten nämlich die hitze weg
und so machte es dann auch im topf
werfen im wasserbad dass wir dann
einfach denn die schüssel ist
unternehmen und jetzt die creme falsch
lag
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal den tortenboden zweimal durch
schneiden dann hab ich nämlich drei
böten
die cremes jetzt schon fast kalt gerührt
und diesen habe ich bereits steif
geschlagen die steht im kühlschrank und
jetzt kann ich hier weitermachen und
kann jetzt die ak tine mit dem wasser in
einen topf geben und das ganze jetzt
verrühren und zwei minuten sprudelnd
aufbauen lassen
jetzt kann ich die creme indiaca team
mit drei und geben die aktie habe ich
natürlich vom herd heruntergezogen
das frühere ich hier im teil
jetzt gebe ich diese agad eine
einmischung wieder zurück in den großen
topf da kann ich das ein bisschen besser
ferkel mit dem rest und da kommt jetzt
noch 250 gramm geschlagene sahne mit
rein und auf diese weise wird und später
auch noch die zim creme hergestellt also
das zimtparfait
die eisenbahn ist jetzt fertig jetzt
kann ich den ersten tortenboden nehmen
da habe ich jetzt einen tortenring meter
außen herum gelegt den stelle ich jetzt
noch ein und trinkt den boden jetzt mit
etwas kaffee zum beispiel ihr könnt aber
auch einen likör nehmen also alles was
ihr möchtet oder können auch ganz
weglassen
aber es bringt einfach mal ein bisschen
geschmack mit rein
ich komme da die vanillecreme drauf dass
man alle parfüms und dadurch dass wir
jetzt diese eier masse eben heißt
aufgeschlagen haben kann jetzt auch
nicht passieren das wäre
krankheitserreger oder kaymer mit drin
haben
deswegen ist auch immer ganz wichtig
dass er die eier vorher ebenheit
behandelt also im prinzip habe ich jetzt
keine rohen eiern drin
ganz vorsichtig verstreichen und stark
kommt jetzt der zweite teigboden drauf
nur ganz leicht andrücken damit die
prämie nicht am rand hoch gedrückt wird
und den boden dann auch tränken
und bevor jetzt aber die zweite creme
drauf kommt werde ich die torte zwar
eine stunde einfrieren damit sie schon
ein bisschen festwirt und die schichten
jetzt nicht zusammen gedrückt werden
in der zwischenzeit kann ich so in etwa
einer halben stunde anfangen die zweite
creme herzustellen
die ziemlich auch die sind creme
verrührt und für den kalten und habe
jetzt auch hier bereits die ak tine
aufkochen lassen und zwei minuten
sprudelnd getaucht und jetzt gebe ich
wieder einteilen
der zimt klingt mir zu aktiv und stand
früher ich alles wieder in den großen
topf miteinander
da kommt es auch die geschlagene sahne
mit rein
dies sorgt dafür dass das café daneben
auch ein bisschen cremig ist unschön
locken
und jetzt kann ich das im café auf den
zweiten tortenboden streichen die torte
setzte ein bisschen angefroren
sie ist voll lecker aus kemmer probieren
ja du mit der zahnlücke superschön sich
da so hier murat santa fe gadebusch ist
jetzt natürlich vorstellen wie macht man
das bekommen sie es vor stars kalt ist
keine fantasie was wir schmecken ja du
kennst doch diese zemis ja genauso
schmeckt ist italien das wird jetzt
gleich noch ein eis im gefrierfach
und damit's nightwish das was da ist ein
echtes cool und sind genau und mit dem
tortenboden oder mit dem deckel mache
ich das jetzt so den stürzt sich jetzt
kurz auf eine tortenplatte als auch
einem zarten retter und kann denn jetzt
auch tränken mit kaffee jetzt wieder
zurück stützen
und jetzt kommt der deckel hier drauf
und dann muss die torte über nach
gekühlt werden über nacht über nacht
wenn der murat nicht schon nachts
aufsteht tja also am besten über nacht
ist jetzt gefragt was ist nur den
gefrierschrank hat murat jetzt am
nächsten tag ist die torte gut
durchgefroren und ich kann sie jetzt
fertig dekorieren und dann auch schon
servieren ihr könnt die torte natürlich
auch mehrere tage aufheben im
gefrierfach natürlich abgedeckt haben
jetzt einfach die torte diesen herr
diesen ski tiefkühl geschmack nicht
annimmt ist sie jetzt gleich auf eine
tortenplatte das lass ich den tortenring
aber noch drum herum und habe hier
bereits sahne steif geschlagen 200 gramm
mit etwas sonderbar und die saale
streiche ich jetzt hier drauf
die gef rädern auch leicht weil er von
unten die kelter der torte kommt
solche 50 gramm tabak ouvertüre habt ihr
in einem gefrierbeutel einfach ein
heißes wasser reingehängt habe es darin
schmelzen lassen
kurz abkühlen lassen und somit den
händen könnt ihr kontrollieren ob die
kuvertüre komplett geschmolzen ist und
jetzt kann ich da oben eine kleine
spitze wegschneiden aufpassen dass wir
jetzt nicht mit 100 jetzt einfach ein
paar kleckse hier drauf geben und es
wird dann gleich ein bisschen marmoriert
jetzt eine gabel nehmen gut das ganze
leicht marmorieren da am besten immer
wieder ein paar kleckse machen dann
durchziehen denn die kuvertüre wird ganz
schnell fest weil er die torte gefordert
und wer möchte kann es mit dem rest der
kuvertüre einfach noch ein paar späne
zurechtschneiden und die noch oben drauf
legen
jetzt kann ich den tortenring lösen und
die eiskarte herausnehmen
ich muss zu meiner schande gestehen
fluglinie eistage gegessen ich glaube
ich nicht dass die zuschauer wissen also
ich würde sagen 95 prozent aller rezepte
machst du nur einmal luft zum ersten mal
dass städte
bisher ist noch nicht viel schief geht
eine schönen weg jetzt total richtig
genial aus jetzt bin ich jetzt mal
richtig
und wer jetzt möchte kann mir gesagt
noch die shopper später drauf geben
ich finde es ehrlich ich bin ja immer
überraschend ob mohring wegkommt was
macht man da steckt und du bist
eigentlich nicht so gespannt drauf geld
und weiß ja ich weiß im kopf schon wie
es aussehen soll und was sagen 'ich
setze rausgekommen aufmachen rauslaufen
akut ist uns auch schon mal passiert
einmal da habe ich das bindemittel
vergessen wird die creme von richtig
genial aus also ich später nämlich jetzt
einmal so ein bisschen um die stücke
dann auch zu kennzeichnen habe ich
später beim schneiden bisserl einfacher
so genial aus schwaig nicht so genial es
kann gar nicht gesund sein
aber die kann man jetzt nicht in küchen
aufgebaut also die müsst ihr auf jeden
fall dann bis zum verzehr natürlich
wieder einfrieren und am besten auch
immer kurz vorm servieren
erst den ring entfernen ansonsten hat
immer abgedeckt lassen weil ich mag es
wirklich gar nicht wenn man was im
gefrierfach oder in deutschland offen
lagert dann schmeckt es immer so nach
kühlschrank und gefrees ob du kann um
nicht nackt und nur die hälfte geschafft
kann man super auf her am besten gleich
in ringnummer genau regele außenrum
toten retter obendrauf oder sonst flexi
deckel und da kann das ist super wieder
einfrieren und du darfst du jetzt
probieren ich
ich glaube ich ich glaub mir kurz auf
und dann auf dem rad probieren also zum
anschneiden da habe ich jetzt ein messer
ein bisschen in heißes wasser getaucht
und jetzt kann ich hier die torte
zurechtschneiden wo das klappt so
juristischer ärger gab es hieß vineta
wenig fahren und nicht zu jung
doch jetzt ist finito
so sieht die torte aus deinen teller
da passt doch gar nicht das große
passende drauf nein mir normalen er
genau da passt farblich das ist also
unten vanille und oben
ja das kann man machen möchte
man muss es eben einfach nur feiern also
unten habe ich an vanille extra
getrennte ebenen oben einfach zimtpulver
ok gespannt ich probiere ich mal ein
bisschen okay
einfach mal was anderes geschlecht cool
mal ganz ehrlich bei dem heißen wetter
ich weiß übrigens einige nette kann
meine eltern meine mama hat mir 47 grad
hat mir 47 grad an wenn wir grillen
wollte meinem fenster aus und genau
wieso hast du warmes wetter ist ein
ideal genau und vor allem kann man jetzt
die torte so bei normalen temperaturen
sag ich jetzt mal ruhig 10 15 mal auf so
stehen lassen
ansonsten bei heißen wir da einfach
gleich wieder einholen
also ich bin ja am sonntag beim fußball
freut mich und zimt und vanille
schmeckt gut raus geld beliebtesten da
ist super
das freut mich also falls jetzt auch
lust bekommen hat auf diese torte könnt
ihr gerne auch sallys - blog.de das
stets noch mal für euch wie gesagt
wandelt die torte gerne auch ab mit den
geschmäckern die academy wenn ihr kein
espresso mit klaas den weg trenk die
torte mit was anderem ganz egal
hauptsache es schmeckt euch ein
hauptziel könnt euch ein bisserl
austoben
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder biss
dann plötzlich wahnsinn entspringt mal
lieber sicherheit wirklich bringt dort
in sicherheit
macht gut